For many people, this is what works sounds like nowadays. It's a constant thrum of notifications, tweets and messages. Every time we respond to an email or a text or Google a question that's just popped into our head, we pay a small price. In the moment, this price is imperceptible, but over time, it adds up. And we haven't quite come to terms with the cost of constant distraction. We treat it, I think, in this more general sense of, I probably should be less distracted, and I think it's more urgent than people realize.
对很多人来说，这就是如今“在工作”的感觉。它伴随着通知、推文和消息的不断轰鸣。每次我们回复电子邮件、短信，或者谷歌一下刚刚浮现在脑海中的问题时，我们都在付出一点代价。在当时，这个代价是微乎其微的，但日积月累，它就会积少成多。而且我们还没有完全接受持续分心所带来的代价。我认为，我们往往以一种更普遍的方式来看待它，觉得我大概应该少分心一点，而我认为这件事比人们意识到的更为紧迫。
Today we look at the challenge of cultivating deep attention and what we gain by immersing ourselves in meaningful work. I spoke to someone who might seem like an unlikely advocate for technological restraint, a computer scientist. Cal Newport is a computer science professor at Georgetown University. He's deliberately tried to break away from the distractions of modern technology and he's trying to get the rest of us to follow his lead. Cal is the author of Deep Work, Rules for Focus Success in a Distracted World. Cal, welcome to Hidden Brain.
今天我们来探讨培养深度专注力的挑战，以及全身心投入有意义的工作能为我们带来什么。我采访了一位看似不太可能是科技克制倡导者的嘉宾，他是一位计算机科学家。卡尔·纽波特（Cal Newport）是乔治顿大学的计算机科学教授。他一直在刻意摆脱现代科技的干扰，并试图让其他人也效仿他的做法。卡尔是《深度工作：如何在干扰世界中获得卓越成就》一书的作者。卡尔，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。
Well, thanks for having me on. You talk on your book about several highly influential thinkers, people like the psychiatrist Carl Jung, the writer's Mark Twain, Jackie Rowling, and you say they all have a set of habits that are quite striking in terms of how they're able to get great work done. This was something I noticed to us very common to influential thinkers, is that they all seem to have this drive to on a regular basis, cut themselves off
谢谢邀请我参加。你在书中谈到了几位极具影响力的思想家，比如精神病学家卡尔·荣格、作家马克·吐温、J·K·罗琳，你说他们在如何高效完成伟大工作方面，都有着一套非常引人注目的习惯。这是我注意到的一点，对极具影响力的思想家来说非常普遍，那就是他们似乎都有这样一种驱动力：定期让自己
from their lives of busyness and communication and distraction and isolate themselves to think deeply. What do they do specifically? Well what you'll notice is that they often will have a location, a separate location they go to when they want to think deeply. That's often cut off from the rest of their life. So Carl Jung would go out to the Bollinger Tower, a stone house without electricity or running water. He built by the lake side outside of a small village in the country's side beyond Zurich. JK Rowling, when she was struggling to finish to Deathly Hallows, rented out this big suite at the Belmore Hotel next to the big castle in downtown Edinburgh,
从忙碌、沟通和分心的生活中抽身出来，将自己隔绝开来进行深度思考。他们具体是怎么做的呢？你会发现，他们通常都有一个地点，一个当他们想要深度思考时会去的分开的地点。这个地点通常与他们生活的其余部分隔离开来。因此，卡尔·荣格会去博林根塔，那是一座没有电也没有自来水的石头房子。那是他在苏黎世郊外一个小村庄旁的湖畔自己建造的。J·K·罗琳在艰难创作《死亡圣器》大结局时，租下了爱丁堡市中心大城堡旁边巴尔莫勒尔酒店的一个大套房，
where she'd go and just think Harry Potter style thoughts. Mark Twain had a cabin for a long period of his life. He would go to on the property of their house. It was so far from the house that his family had to blow a horn to try to catch his attention and let him know that dinner was ready. They go somewhere physically isolated and different where they can without distraction think deeply. What does work look like for the rest of us?
她会去那里，思考哈利·波特式的宏大构想。马克·吐温在其生命中的很长一段时间里，也在自家产业的领地上建了一个小屋。它离主房子太远了，以至于他的家人不得不吹号角来吸引他的注意，好让他知道晚餐准备好了。他们会去一个物理上孤立且不同的地方，在那里不受干扰地进行深度思考。那么，对于我们其余人来说，工作是什么样的呢？
When you look at the average American worker, for example, are most of us doing this kind of deep, sustained work? The type of deep work I talk about is almost non-existent as far as I can tell in most knowledge work positions, even when people think that they're single-tasking. They say, I've learned a lesson that I'm not supposed to multitask. I'm not supposed to be on the phone and do email while I write. I'm just working on one thing at a time. What they're still doing is every five or ten minutes a just check. Let me just do a just check to my inbox. Let me just do a just check to my phone real quick and then back to my work. And it feels like single tasking. It
例如，当你审视普通美国工人时，我们大多数人都在进行这种深入、持续的工作吗？据我所知，在我所涉及的大多数知识型工作岗位上，我所谈论的那种深度工作几乎是不存在的，即使人们认为自己在进行单任务处理。他们会说：“我吸取了教训，不应该同时处理多项任务。我在写作时既不应该接电话，也不应该看邮件。我一次只专心做一件事。”但他们仍然在做的是：每隔五到十分钟就“顺便检查一下”。让我顺便检查一下收件箱。让我快速顺便检查一下手机，然后再回到工作。这感觉像是单任务处理。它
feels like you're predominantly working on one thing, but even those very brief checks that switch your context even briefly can have this massive negative impact on your cognitive performance, is to switch itself that hurts, not how long you actually switch. So I actually think even very conscientious knowledge workers who think they're pretty good at focusing on one negative time are actually still working far from the sort of high performance, deep work ideal. What is the evidence that the switching causes harm to the quality of your thinking?
感觉你主要在专注于一件事，但即使是那些极其短暂、甚至短暂改变你语境的检查，也会对你的认知表现产生巨大的负面影响。伤害你的是切换本身，而不是你实际切换了多久。因此，我甚至认为，那些认为自己非常擅长一次专注于一件事的认真知识工作者，其实际工作状态距离高性能的“深度工作”理想状态还相去甚远。有什么证据表明这种切换会损害思维质量呢？
Well, we've seen the show up in different types of scientific studies and from different types of perspectives. I think one angle that makes it pretty clear is to work that Professor Sophie Leroy has done on an effect called attention residue. This is actually something that's pretty easy to isolate in the laboratory. You essentially give a subject something cognitively demanding to do that you can measure, like trying to solve hard puzzles. And then at some point, you distract them briefly as the experimenter, have them look at something
嗯，我们已经在不同类型的科学研究中以及从不同的角度看到了这种现象。我认为有一个角度非常清晰，那就是索菲·勒鲁瓦（Sophie Leroy）教授针对一种名为“注意力残留”的效应所做的工作。这其实是在实验室里很容易分离出来的一种现象。你基本上是给受试者一些需要消耗认知的、可衡量的任务，比如尝试解开高难度的谜题。然后在某个时刻，作为实验人员，你短暂地打断他们，让他们看别的东西，
else change their context very briefly. When they then turn back to the original, coagulid demanding task, you see the performance drops. And it drops for a while. It takes a while for this attention residue to clear out. And this is essentially what we're doing to ourselves when we do that quick glance at the inbox or to the phone. I'm talking with Carol Newport.
非常短暂地改变他们的语境。当他们随后转回原来那个高认知要求的任务时，你会发现他们的表现下降了。而且这种下降会持续一段时间。这种注意力残留需要一段时间才能清除。这本质上就是我们在快速浏览收件箱或手机时对自己的大脑所做的事情。我正在与卡尔·纽波特进行交谈。
He is a computer science professor at Georgetown University and the author of Deep Work rules for focus success in a distracted world. Kalim wondering, do you think most of us are aware of the costs of distraction in our lives? People, I think, intuit that they're too distracted and it's making them feel fragmented and exhausted and anxious, but we treat it, I think, in this more general sense of, I probably should be less distracted, and I think it's more urgent than people realize that if your brain is how you make a living, then you really have to worry about this cognitive fitness. I mean, how are you getting performance out of your brain? Are you taking care to get
他是乔治顿大学的计算机科学教授，也是《深度工作：如何在干扰世界中获得卓越成就》一书的作者。卡尔，我想知道，你认为我们大多数人意识到生活中分心的代价了吗？我认为，人们直觉上觉得自己分心太严重了，这让他们感到支离破碎、筋疲力尽和焦虑，但我们对待它的方式，我认为更偏向于一种普遍的感觉，即“我大概应该少分心一点”。我认为这件事比人们意识到的更具紧迫性，因为如果你的大脑是你谋生的工具，那么你真的必须关心这种认知健康。也就是说，你是如何从你的大脑中榨取性能的？你是否有意去确保
good performance out of your brain or not? And people would probably be surprised the more they think about it, how much they're leaving on the table, by the way they're currently working. Does it matter that most of us are not trying to win a Nobel Prize or a Pulitzer Prize, that we're not necessarily genius? Does it actually matter for most of us that we don't regularly put ourselves in a state of deep work? Well, this is a big shift that I think has happened in our economy because it's an
你的大脑能够发挥出良好的性能呢？如果人们多加思考，可能会对自己在当前的这种工作方式下究竟错失了多少潜力感到惊讶。我们大多数人并不打算赢得诺贝尔奖或普利策奖，我们也不一定都是天才，这重要吗？对于我们大多数人来说，不让自己经常处于深度工作状态，真的有关系吗？好吧，我认为我们的经济发生了一个巨大的转变，因为在我们的经济中，
increasing portion of our economy because it's an increasing portion of our economy that are essentially making a living by using their brain to process information and produce new information. And even if you're not trying to write great literature or solve a great theorem, if you're using your brain primarily to produce value, be it writing, marketing, copy, or putting together a new plan for your business start up. These type of things matter. The human brain has become one of the main capital resources in our economy. It's what in the knowledge economy we spend most of our money on is supporting human brains to process things and
由于它在我们经济中所占的比例越来越大，因为在我们经济中，越来越多的人本质上是通过使用大脑来处理信息并产出新信息来谋生的。即使你不是在试图写出伟大的文学作品或解开伟大的定理，如果你主要是在用大脑来创造价值——无论是写作、营销文案，还是为你的初创企业制定新计划。这些事情都很重要。人类的大脑已经成为了我们经济中最主要的资本资源之一。在知识经济中，我们把绝大多数资金都花在支持人类大脑处理事情和
produce value. So we should care. I think the ability to deep work would be relevant to the professional success of almost everyone in the knowledge work field, which is a huge part of our economy. I'd like to run a little thought experiment. Imagine we're following a doctor as she's making the rounds of a hospital, and she's looking at many patients, and presumably the patients all present with different problems and complications and so forth. And I think what we would expect is for this doctor to very quickly flip from one subject, one topic, one patient to the next. That if we, if the doctor were to say, you know, I can only do my best work. If I can focus on one patient, deeply understand that case, spend a lot of time with it.
创造价值上。所以我们应该在乎。我认为，进行深度工作能力对知识工作领域的几乎每个人的职业成功都息息相关，而这在我们经济中占了很大一部分。我想做一个小小的思想实验。假设我们跟着一位医生去查房，她要看很多病人，想必这些病人们都有着不同的问题、并发症等等。我想我们所预料的是，这位医生会非常迅速地从一个主题、一个话题、一个病人切断并转换到下一个。如果我们——如果这位医生说：“你知道的，我只有在能够专注服务一个病人、深入了解那个病例、并在上面花大量时间的情况下，才能做出最好的工作。”
Yes, that might be true, but it's going to come at a cost, which is all the other patients that the doctor is not going to see. What are the costs of deep work? Well where I'd want to get with the doctor is just the ability even if you're relatively briefly staying with each patient to actually be able to stay just with that patient. So a case study I uncovered actually after the book came out was of two different groups at the same elite level residency. One group had a culture of email. So, hey, I need something here's a question, what about this patient?
是的，这也许是真的，但这是有代价的，这个代价就是医生将无法照顾其他所有病人。深度工作有什么代价呢？好吧，我希望这位医生能够达到的状态是，即使她在每个病人身上停留的时间相对短暂，也能够真正做到“只专注于眼前这个病人”。事实上，我在这本书出版后发现的一个案例研究来自同一精英级别住院医师项目的两个不同小组。其中一个小组有着电子邮件文化。也就是：“嘿，我这里有个问题，这个病人怎么样？”
And they're expected that the constantly be available by email, the other group consolidated that type of administrative or logistical conversations to set meetings. And what the doctor from that hospital told me is that they had a real hard time keeping people in that first group, where in the second group people were much happier. So deep work doesn't necessarily mean I can sit half a day and just think about this one
他们被期望随时通过电子邮件保持在线；而另一个小组则将这类行政或后勤沟通整合到固定的会议中去。那位来自该医院的医生告诉我，他们在第一组很难留住人，而在第二组，大家要快乐得多。因此，深度工作并不一定意味着我可以坐上半天时间只考虑这一个
patient, but just the ability to walk into a room and just think about that patient and not have to see 16 emails as you walk into the next room and have that eating away at your attention, that can really make a big difference. You said that the people who were engaged in deep work ended up being happier, so it's not just a question of being more productive, but you're making the case that deep work produces a kind of intrinsic reward that doesn't come from being distracted? It seems to, and in fact this caught me off guard when I was researching my book. I ended up adding a chapter to the book that was not in the original proposal. That was all about these findings I kept coming across and these stories I kept coming across about deep living, also just
病人，但只要有能力走进一个房间只思考那个病人，而不必在走进下一个房间时看到16封邮件并在脑海里不断蚕食你的注意力，这真的能带来巨大的改变。你说过，那些从事深度工作的人最终会更快乐，所以这不仅仅是一个提高生产力的问题，你的观点是，深度工作能带来一种无法通过分心获得内在奖赏？似乎确实如此，事实上，当我在研究这本书时，这让我感到很意外。我最后在书中加了一章，这一章在最初的提案中是没有的。那一章全部关于我不断遇到的这些发现，以及我不断听到的关于深度生活的那些故事，它们同时也意味着
being good living. People who spend a larger proportion of the professional time concentrating intensely on a single high skill or high craft target, tend to enjoy their work a lot more. There's a lot of different factors about why that might be true, but I ended by saying a deep life is a good life. And that's something I really believe in. It can take a knowledge work career and make it much more satisfying than being in a persistent state of putting out fires and busy distraction. Can you cite any professions where deep work is probably not called for and might even be a problem? Sure, there's plenty of examples I think
美好的生活。那些将职业生涯中更大比例的时间集中在单一高技能或高工艺目标上的人，往往会从工作中获得更多的乐趣。关于为什么会这样，有很多不同的因素，但我在书末总结道：深度生活就是美好的生活。这是我真心相信的一点。它可以重塑知识工作的职业生涯，使其比长期处于救火状态和忙乱分心中要满意得多。你能举出一些可能不需要深度工作、甚至可能产生问题的职业吗？当然，我认为有很多例子
where deep work is probably not that relevant. A couple of the common examples I give is actually, I think being a CEO of a large company, you're probably going to better serve your company or stockholders by being a decision engine for other people who are doing deep work. Someone who people can come to, okay, what about this? What should we do here?
深度工作可能并不那么相关。我给出的几个常见例子是，比如担任大公司的首席执行官，你可能通过成为其他进行深度工作的人的“决策引擎”，来更好地服务于你的公司或股东。一个大家可以来找他寻求意见的人：“好吧，这个怎么办？我们在这里应该做什么？”
You can be a consistent source of the vision and push these decisions in a consistent way. Another example is, let's say you're in what they would call here in DC, government relations, where really most of what you do is context and connections and connecting the right people to the right other people and keeping up with what's going on in people's lives. That's another example of a place where long solitary concentration is not going to make a difference. I think there's plenty of jobs, in other words, in which deep work doesn't make a difference. But I've also found, in my experience, that the number of jobs for which this is true is smaller than people expect. You make the argument in the book that there are lots of blue-collar jobs, jobs where you're working with your hands, where deep work actually produces much better work and also produces much better engagement with the work.
你可以成为愿景的持续来源，并以一致的方式推动这些决策。另一个例子是，假设你处于华盛顿特区所说的政府关系部门，在这里你所做的大多数事情实际上都是人脉、关系，将合适的人与合适的人联系起来，并跟进了解人们生活中发生的事情。这是另一个长时间独处专注无法发挥作用的例子。换句话说，我认为有很多工作，深度工作在其中并不会带来什么改变。但我也发现，根据我的经验，符合这种情况的工作数量其实比人们预期的要少。你在书中提出，有很多蓝领工作，也就是用双手工作的工作，深度工作实际上能带来更好的成果，也能让人更好地投入到工作中去。
Right, I think the connection between concentration and craft is actually clearer in a lot of these fields. If you talk to a craftsman, they will tell you immediately. Well, obviously, obviously you need to focus intensely, otherwise you're going to make a mistake, you're not going to produce the best quality work, you're going to get feedback immediately that you are less effective if you're more distracted. And a big part of the argument I'm making is that there's nothing different enough about a world that takes place on screens for this no longer to be true. So if you talk to true craftsmen, they already know the power of deep work. And so in some sense, we're just taking this message and bringing it up the speed for the 21st century.
没错，我认为在许多这些领域中，专注与手艺之间的联系实际上更加清晰。如果你和手艺人交谈，他们会立刻告诉你。好吧，很显然，很显然你需要高度专注，否则你就会犯错，你就无法产出最高质量的工作，如果你分心了，你就会立即得到反馈，证明你的效率变低了。而我提出的论点很大一部分在于，一个发生在屏幕上的世界并没有什么本质上的不同，以至于这种规律不再适用。因此，如果你与真正的工匠交谈，他们已经知道了深度工作的力量。所以从某种意义上说，我们只是在把这个信息带向现代化，以适应21世纪的节奏。
It seems to me that there are connections here with ideas related to mindfulness, or ideas related to flow that you should be in the moment focused on what you're doing. It seems to me that those ideas are intimately connected with deep work. They are connected. So deep work can induce flow states, which is one of the reasons why people find a career push more towards deep work is more satisfying. It's not entirely synonymous with flow. We know there's other types of states that also count as deep work that would not fall under
在我看来，这与正念相关的理念，或者与心流相关的理念有着某种联系，即你应该活在当下，专注於你正在做的事情。在我看来，这些理念与深度工作是紧密相连的。它们确实是相连的。因此，深度工作可以诱发心流状态，这也是为什么人们发现将职业生涯更多地推向深度工作会更有满足感的原因之一。它并不完全等同于心流。我们知道，还有其他类型状态也属于深度工作，但并不符合
most definitions of flow. So for example, being in a state of deliberate practice where you're systematically pushing your skills past or you're comfortable so that you can improve, that's different than a flow state. It doesn't feel pleasurable. You don't lose yourself in the time. When you're practicing like that, you feel every single second because it's very difficult. But that also falls under the umbrella of deep work. And what about mindfulness? The idea that we should just be immersed in what we are doing,
心流的大多数定义。例如，处于刻意练习的状态中，你系统地将自己的技能推向舒适区之外，以便不断进步，这与心流状态是不同的。它并不令人愉悦。你不会在时间中忘我。当你这样练习时，你会感受到每一秒钟，因为这非常困难。但这同样属于深度工作的范畴。那么正念呢？那种认为我们应该沉浸在正在做的事情中的理念，
paying attention to what's going on in the moment. There are connections to mindfulness. And one of the more important connections is that we know from the study and practice of mindfulness, such as mindfulness meditation, that getting better at that type of presence is something that requires practice and training. And we see this exactly happening with deep work and a professional setting. It's something that you train and get better at, just like you can get better at certain types of meditation, that it's something you have to work at systematically. It's a skill to be practiced, not a habit that you already know how to do and just try to make more time for.
关注当下发生的事情。这与正念是有联系的。其中一个更重要的联系是，我们从正念的研究和实践（例如正念冥想）中得知，提高这种临在感是需要练习和培训的。我们在职业环境中的深度工作身上也看到了完全相同的情况。这是你需要训练并加以改进的技能，就像你可以通过某些类型的冥想来获得提升一样，这是你必须系统性地去努力的事情。它是一项需要练习的技能，而不是一个你本来就懂、只需试着挤出更多时间去做的习惯。
Cal Newport is the author of the book Deepwork, rules for focus success in a distracted world. When we come back, we'll talk about how you can retrain your mind to focus, to sit with a single idea for a long period of time. And we'll talk about whether creating a deep work culture for some people means that others will inevitably have to pick up the slack. I'm Shankar Vedantam and you're listening to Hidden Brain. Stay with us. This is NPR. Welcome back to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. I'm speaking to Kal Newport, a Georgetown University computer science professor, who's the author of the book Deepwork.
卡尔·纽波特是《深度工作：如何在干扰世界中获得卓越成就》一书的作者。稍后回来，我们将探讨如何重新训练你的大脑去专注，去长时间地与一个单一想法共处。我们还将探讨，为一部分人创造深度工作文化是否意味着其他人不可避免地必须承担起由此带来的额外负担。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam），你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。请不要走开。这里是NPR。欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我正在与乔治顿大学计算机科学教授卡尔·纽波特交谈，他是《深度工作》一书的作者。
It's about how we can cultivate the ability to focus on work, free of all distraction. Kal leads an enormously disciplined life with lots of rules and rituals. I asked him to explain how he structures his day to allow plenty of time for focused work. There's a few things I do. One is I've never had a social media account and that's on purpose. It's not that I think I'm better than social media but to quote George Packer's essay on this is because I'm afraid I'll let my kids go hungry if I expose myself to that. So that's one thing I do. Two, I'm very organized with my time. I work during very set hours during the day
这本书讲的是我们如何培养专注于工作、摆脱所有干扰的能力。卡尔过着极其自律的生活，有着许多规则和仪式。我请他解释他是如何安排自己的一天，以便为专注的工作留出充足时间的。我有几个习惯。首先，我从来没有注册过社交媒体账号，这是故意的。并不是我觉得自己比社交媒体高明，而是引用乔治·帕克（George Packer）对此事的文章中的话来说，是因为我害怕如果我接触那些东西，我会让我的孩子挨饿。所以这是我做的第一件事。第二，我对自己的时间非常有规划。我会在一天中非常固定的时间工作，
and I plan out the day like a chess player moving the pieces around. This is when I'm gonna work on win. I don't let my mood dictate how my day unfolds. And then three, I've made myself very comfortable with annoying people. I'm bad at email. I have just set the expectations that I'm just not available a lot.
并像国际象棋选手在棋盘上移动棋子一样规划我的一天。这是我决定要在什么时候做什么事的时间。我不会让自己的情绪来决定我的一天如何展开。第三，我让自己非常习惯于去惹恼别人。我不擅长处理邮件。我已经设定了这样的预期：我就是没有那么多时间。
I'm not someone that you can expect a quick answer from. And that also causes some trouble, of course, but all this adds up to allowing me to regularly have long portions of many of my days focused on deeper thinking. I understand you actually keep a tally of how much deep work you've done, how many hours you've spent being uninterrupted, and you actually have targets that you must meet at the end of the day or the end of the week.
我不是那种你能指望得到快速回复的人。当然，这也会带来一些麻烦，但所有这些加起来，让我能够在许多天的很长一段时间里专注于更深层次的思考。我听说你实际上会记录你做了多少深度工作，花了多少小时没有被打扰，并且你确实有必须在一天结束或一周结束时达成的目标。
Yeah, that's right. This is something until recently I was doing, I was tallying how many deep work hours, so I had to confront that. I had to confront the reality. So if I was really avoiding deep work, I would see it. I've since added a new habit to my arsenal here where I now block out my deep work on my calendar up to four weeks in advance. So I have
是的，没错。直到最近我还在这样做，我在统计深度工作的时长，所以我必须正视这一点。我必须正视现实。所以如果我真的在逃避深度工作，我一眼就能看出来。从那以后，我在自己的武器库中增加了一个新习惯，我现在会在日历上提前最多四周圈出我的深度工作时间。所以我有
that time protected so far out in the future that I can be sure it'll stay protected. So now I have a record on my calendar of exactly what deep work I'm doing. I understand you have a fairly structured approach to shutting down at the end of the day, of making sure that the tasks that remain unfinished don't bleed into your evening and your family life. I have an actual ritual I do at the end of each workday where it pretty systematically, I'll look at my weekly plan, I'll look at my task licks, I'll look at my calendar,
足够超前的时间受到保护，从而确保它能一直受到保护。因此，现在我的日历上有一份记录，精确记录了我正在进行的深度工作。我听说你在一天结束时有一套相当结构化的收尾方法，以确保那些未完成的任务不会渗入你的傍晚和家庭生活。我在每个工作日结束时确实有一套仪式，我会非常系统地查看我的每周计划，查看我的任务清单，查看我的日历，
make sure that nothing is left hanging, and then I'll do a little shutdown mantra make sure that nothing is left hanging, and then I'll do a little shutdown mantra. You'll say an actual phrase that means I'm now done work for the day. What's the phrase that you tell yourself at the end of the day? I used to be embarrassed to admit, the phrase was schedule shutdown complete, but I now have this small but strong fan group that used that exact same phrase proudly. So now I'm willing to admit, it's schedule shut down complete.
确保没有任何事情被悬置，然后我会念一句小小的收尾咒语确保没有任何事情被悬置，然后我会念一句小小的收尾咒语。你会说出一句真正意味着“我今天的工作到此为止”的话。你一天结束时对自己说的那句话是什么？我过去曾羞于承认，那句话是“计划关闭完成”，但我现在有了一群虽然人数不多但很坚定的粉丝群体，他们也在自豪地使用完全相同的那句话。所以我现在愿意承认，就是“计划关闭完成”。
Do you say this without this around? No. It doesn't really matter what the phrase is. I invented that phrase when I was a graduate student working on my dissertation. It was really having a hard time with coming home from the office and having all these concerns. Hey, what if this proof never fixes or what if this proof breaks, what if my dissertation falls apart?
你说这话时周围有人吗？没有。这句话具体是什么其实并不重要。我在当研究生写学位论文时发明了这句话。当时我真的很难做到从办公室回家后还能放下所有这些担忧。嘿，万一这个证明永远无法修复怎么办？或者万一这个证明被推翻了，万一我的学位论文泡汤了怎么办？
And I needed something to allow me to definitively shut down. And so I was younger then, I came up with this phrase, but now it became habit, so I stuck with it. Kyle Newport is a computer science professor at Georgetown University, and he's talking about his book Deepwork, Rules for Focus Success in a Distracted World. Cal, what would you say to people who say, you're asking us to turn into computers, you're asking us to behave like robots? Well, see, I would argue that that's what people are doing right now. We've turned ourselves into sort of human network routers. We just sit here and process messages and sort through task lists and have this sense of busyness
我需要某种东西来让我彻底关闭工作状态。所以我那时还比较年轻，就想出了这句话，但现在它成了习惯，所以我就一直用下去了。卡尔·纽波特是乔治顿大学的计算机科学教授，他正在谈论他的书《深度工作：如何在干扰世界中获得卓越成就》。卡尔，你会对那些说“你是在要求我们变成计算机，你是在要求我们像机器人一样行事”的人说些什么呢？嗯，你看，我会争辩说，这正是人们现在正在做的事情。我们把自己变成了某种人类网络路由器。我们只是坐在那里处理消息、筛选任务清单，并怀有一种忙碌感，
that treats our mind like a digital computer processor, something that you just feed instructions to and it executes one after another. I think what I'm doing is actually way more human. This idea that our brain is not like a computer, it's not like any other machine we know, it's something that you have a personal connection to and it's something that you really have to take care of,
这种感觉把我们的大脑当作数字计算机处理器，一种你只要向其输入指令它就会一个接一个执行的东西。我认为我正在做的事情实际上要人性得多。这种认为我们的大脑不像计算机、不像我们所知的任何其他机器的理念，它是一个你与之有着个人联系的东西，它是你真正需要去呵护的东西，
something that you have to coax high performance out of. So to have a structured day, for example, to protect your mind from distraction, I actually think makes you more human and less robotic than what most people do, which is to sit there like a human network router and just sort of process messages and tasks all day like a blind computer processor.
是一个你需要从中榨取出高性能的东西。因此，例如拥有一个结构化的一天，保护你的大脑免受干扰，实际上会让你变得更有同理心、更具人性，而没有那么像机器人——相比之下，大多数人的做法是像人类网络路由器一样坐在那里，整天像一个盲目的计算机处理器一样只处理消息和任务。
There seems to be a paradox here because I think what I'm hearing you say is that scheduling yourself or even over scheduling yourself is the way to actually gain control over your life. Whereas people would sort of say if you're actually scheduling every second and sort of deciding four weeks ahead of time when you're going to stop work on a certain Wednesday, you've actually turned yourself into a robot. It's a paradox that shows up a lot. It confuses people, but I think you're right to point it out is that if you study, especially really creative people, professional creatives, they are surprisingly structured in how they approach their day. I took a quote at one point from
这其中似乎存在一个悖论，因为我认为我听到你说的是，对自己进行时间规划、甚至过度规划，才是真正获得生活掌控权的方法。然而人们通常会认为，如果你真的把每一秒都规划好，并且提前四周决定好你将在某个周三的什么时间停止工作，你实际上就把自己变成了一个机器人。这是一个经常出现的悖论。它把人们搞糊涂了，但我认为你指出来是对的：如果你去研究，特别是那些真正富有创造力的人、专业创作者，他们在对待自己的一天时，有着令人惊讶的结构化。我曾经引用过
David Brooks to columnist and I might be paraphrasing here. But basically, he pointed out this observation that great creative thinkers approach their time like accountants. That this is this great disconnect is that they're very structured and systematic about their time and produce the most unstructured, brilliant creative insights. So it's a key paradox to point out because I really want to emphasize it. Adding structure and control to your time really can be the key to getting the biggest insights and most interesting work produced.
专栏作家大卫·布鲁克斯（David Brooks）的一句话，我这里可能是意译。但基本上，他指出了这样一个观察结果：伟大的创造性思想家对待他们的时间就像会计师一样。这就是一个巨大的断层：他们对自己的时间非常结构化、系统化，却产出了最不具结构性、最精妙的创造性洞见。所以这是一个需要指出的关键悖论，因为我真的想强调这一点：为你的时间添加结构和控制，确实可以是获得最大洞见和产出最具价值工作的关键。
I'm wondering if part of the tension comes about because we actually think of inspiration as being the thing that strikes us unexpectedly. And I think the case that you're making is that inspiration actually can be scheduled to arrive on command. Well, Chuck Close said the artist's inspiration is for amateurs. I think we over focus on the inspiration piece. If you're systematically pushing yourself and your knowledge and your craft, you will have inspiration.
我想知道，这种紧张感的一部分是否源于我们实际上认为灵感是不期而至的东西？而我认为你提出的观点是，灵感实际上是可以被安排按时降临的。查克·克洛斯（Chuck Close）曾说过，艺术家的灵感是留给业余爱好者的。我认为我们过分关注灵感这部分了。如果你系统性地推动自己、你的知识和你的手艺，你就会产生灵感。
It'll happen in the shower, it'll happen while you walk to work. What's important is, you know, setting yourself up to have that inspiration and then giving yourself the time and structure you need to act on it, to actually produce something of value out of it. So I downplay the importance of inspiration and I emphasize the importance of creating a life or inspiration as possible and you're well suited to act on it. I want to ask you a couple of questions that push back against this idea from a practical standpoint. What if people are in workplaces
它会在你洗澡时出现，它会在你步行上班时出现。重要的是，你要（你知道的）让自己准备好迎接这种灵感，然后给自己需要的时间和结构去对它采取行动，从中真正产出有价值的东西。所以我淡化了灵感的重要性，而强调创造一种让灵感成为可能的生活，并且让你有能力对它采取行动。我想问你几个从实用角度反驳这种观点的的问题。如果人们身处这样的职场中：
where they have managers and bosses who aren't enlightened enough to say, yes, you should spend several hours engaged in deep work? People can't always choose for themselves what kind of work they pursue. Something that has seemed to be effective is in that type of situation, having a conversation with whoever your boss is, whoever supervises you. And so I want to talk about deep work. Here's what deep work is. I want to talk about non-deep worker shallow work. And here's what that is. And both are important to my job. And I want to have a conversation and decide what should my ratio be?
他们的经理和老板并没有开明到对他们说：“是的，你应该花几个小时进行深度工作”？人们并不能总是为自己选择追求什么样的工作。在那种情况下，似乎行之有效的一件事是与你的老板、任何监督你的人进行一次对话。所以我想谈谈深度工作。这就是深度工作。我想谈谈非深度工作或浅薄工作。这就是它的内容。这两者对我的工作都很重要。我想进行一次对话，并决定我的比例应该是什么？
That isn't a typical work week. What ratio of my hours should be deep work versus shallow work? And actually nailing down a number and aspirational target that everyone agrees, yeah, this is right for your position in our company. It's not saying, hey, boss, stop emailing me so much. You annoy me. It's instead saying, hey, let's try to optimize myself.
在一个典型的工作周中，我的时间中有多少比例应该是深度工作，多少应该是浅薄工作？并且真正确定一个数字和大家都能一致认同的渴望目标，即“是的，这很适合你在我们公司的职位”。这并不是说：“嘿，老板，别再给我发那么多邮件了。你真烦人。”相反，它说的是：“嘿，让我们试着优化我。”
So what should I be going for here? Let me get your feedback on this. And people are reporting back to me, tales of drastic changes to work cultures. Did they thought, there's no way? There's no way I'm gonna get away with this. I'm supposed to be on Slack all the time or I'm supposed to be answering my emails all the time.
所以我在这里应该追求什么？让我听听你的反馈。人们向我反馈的是工作文化发生剧烈变化的种种故事。他们原本以为：“这是不可能的。我绝不可能蒙混过关。我应该一直在线使用Slack，或者我应该一直回复邮件。”
They have this conversation in the next week. They're spending 50% of their hours on distracted. So I've been pushing that particular managerial hack as a good positive way forward to trying to fix some of these issues. I'm wondering if some people might say your advice is really advice for people who in some ways are at the top of their food chains. So if you have an author who basically is able to say I'm going to disconnect from the world for 18 months, I'm just going to focus on writing this book. You know, someone else
他们在接下来的一周里进行了这次对话。他们把50%的时间花在了分心上。所以我一直在推行那个特定的管理小技巧，将其作为解决其中一些问题的一个很好的积极途径。我想知道，有些人可能会说，你的建议实际上是针对那些在某种程度上处于食物链顶端的人的建议。所以如果你有一个作家，他基本上可以说：“我要与世隔绝18个月，我只要专心写这本书。”你知道，另一个人
is probably picking up after this person in all kinds of different ways. If Cal Newport says, you know, I'm going to close the door in my office, I'm not going to answer my phone, I'm not going to check my email, but someone needs to get in touch with you in an emergency. That person is probably going to reach an assistant of yours, and that assistant doesn't have the same luxury of deep work as you do because he or she needs to be available to hear what the emergency is or to hear what the request is. Does having a group of people who are engaged in deep work necessarily mean they must be essentially a second tier of workers who are engaged in shallow work to allow the deep thinkers to do that deep thinking.
可能会以各种不同的方式来收拾这个人的烂摊子。如果卡尔·纽波特说：“你知道的，我要关上办公室的门，我不接电话，我不查邮件，”但如果有人有紧急情况需要联系你呢？这个人很可能只能联系到你的助理，而那个助理并没有像你那样享有深度工作的奢侈，因为他或她需要随时待命，以了解紧急情况是什么或请求是什么。拥有一群从事深度工作的人，是否必然意味着他们本质上必须是一群从事浅薄工作的第二梯队员工，从而为深度思考者进行深度思考创造条件？
It doesn't require that, but it usually requires some type of reconfiguration of communication channels and expectations. So when I work for example with people maybe in a small consultancy that is client facing. Where they're used to this idea that clients need to reach us issues pop up. What's important there to enable more deep work, which in the end produces more value for everyone, is just to actually change the communication expectations. That may be instead of having a client, just have individual people's email addresses,
这并不需要这样，但它通常需要对沟通渠道和期望进行某种形式的重新配置。例如，当我与某些面向客户的小型咨询公司的人合作时。他们习惯了这种观点：客户需要联系我们，问题随时会出现。在那里，为了实现更多深度工作（这最终能为所有人创造更多价值），重要的是去改变沟通期望。也许不再让客户直接发邮件给个人，
the company sets up an email address for that client. And the company has set up some agreement on there in that there will always be someone monitoring that and here's the expectation of when you can get a response. Or maybe setting up a, sometimes called the bat phone or emergency phone idea, where you say, okay, here's a, here's a number you can call me at. If there's an emergency when I'm in one of these deep work sessions, people set these up and say they get called maybe once a year. So I don't think you need actual
公司为该客户设置一个专门的邮箱。并且公司已经对此达成了一切协议，即总会有人在监控那个邮箱，并且这里有一个关于你何时能得到回复的预期。或者可能设置一个有时被称为“红色电话”或紧急电话的概念，即你说：“好吧，这里有一个号码，如果有紧急情况，当我处于这些深度工作会议中的时候，你可以拨打这个号码。”人们设置了这些，并说他们可能一年才被打扰一次。所以我不认为你需要实际的
extra people involved to make space for DeBoard But I do think it almost always requires some effort some sort of Reconfiguration of people's expectations on on how and when they can reach you So I'm gonna ask your question now that's part serious and part teasing You and I was scheduled to talk last week, and you didn't get the appointment down in your calendar, and I was sitting here waiting for you,
额外人员来为深度工作腾出空间，但我确实认为它几乎总是需要一些努力，对人们关于如何以及何时可以联系到你的期望进行某种重新配置。所以我现在要问你一个半认真、半开玩笑的问题。你和我原定于上周通话，但你没有把预约记在日历上，我当时就坐在那儿等着你，
and of course, this kind of thing happens all the time, but in your case, I couldn't help but wonder, did he miss this because he actually hadn't spent the time doing the shallow work to get this in his calendar? And is it possible that when we engage in deep work, we are essentially getting the benefit of all of that deep work, we're getting the deep thinking, we're getting the accomplishments, but some of the cost is borne by other people, and they might actually be the people who are getting mad at you when they can't reach you?
当然，这种事情经常发生，但在你的情况下，我忍不住想：他是因为没有花时间做那些浅薄的工作把这件事记在日历上才错过的吗？有没有可能，当我们进行深度工作时，我们基本上享受到了所有深度工作的好处——我们获得了深度思考，我们取得了成就，但其中一部分代价是由其他人承担的，而他们实际上可能就是那些因为联系不上你而对你生气的人？
Well, it's a good point, and I think that's actually was what happened because I spend a lot of time working away from my computer. These type of problems happen to me more often. In this case, and I'm embarrassed it happened, but my vague memory was I saw this communication on my phone because I had to be on there to send something to someone, but I was far away from a computer. I wasn't able to easily add it to a calendar. And I was like, okay, I'll remember to do this
好吧，这是一个很好的观点，我想这实际上就是发生的事情，因为我花了很多时间远离电脑工作。这类问题更频繁地发生在我身上。在这种情况下——对此我感到很尴尬——我依稀的记忆是，我在手机上看到了这个沟通，因为我必须在上面给某人发点东西，但我离电脑很远。我没法轻易把它加到日历里。当时我想：“好吧，我记得做这件事……”
when I get back to my office next night for God. And it did cause problems. And so I'm embarrassed about it. And that type of thing does happen. And I think this hits on a big point, which is deep work, or a professional life focused on deep work, is less convenient for most people involved. But on the other hand, I want to put out there this notion that that might not be so bad,
等我那天晚些时候回到办公室时就忘得精光了。这确实造成了问题。所以我对此感到很尴尬。这种事情确实会发生。我认为这触及了一个重大观点，那就是：深度工作，或者说一个专注于深度工作的职业生涯，对所涉及的大多数人来说确实不那么方便。但从另一方面来看，我想提出这样一种观点：这也许并不是一件坏事，
that it's possible that in this age of digital communication, we are focusing too much on convenience over effectiveness. I think in some ways what you're saying is also the tension between the short term and the long term. If I don't respond to a colleague's request or a manager's instructions to do something right away, it's irritating for the person at the other end of the line. And so I think most of us actually conformed to the social norm of saying, yes, I'm just going to be responsive, I'm going to be available, I'm going to answer the question as soon as it's asked. The point that you're making, though,
在数字通信的这个时代，我们可能过于关注便利性而忽视了有效性。我认为在某些方面，你所说的话也体现了短期与长期之间的张力。如果我对同事的请求或经理指导做某事的指令没有立即做出回应，对于线那头的人来说是令人恼火的。所以我认为我们大多数人都顺从了这样一种社会规范，即：“是的，我只要随叫随到，我只要有求必应，一旦问题被提出，我就马上回答。”然而你提出的观点是，
is that they might be long term goals, deeper institutional goals that are essentially we're not thinking about. And of course, when those goals are not met because they're not articulated, no one notices their absence. So people will notice it if you don't show up at an interview, people are not going to notice it if you don't write that bestseller or the next great idea. And so there's really a cultural bias in favor of the trivial over protecting what actually is most important. I really agree with that point, and I would add to it that I think a big part of it is lack of metrics. So if we look at two parallel case studies, two different industries.
可能存在着长期的、我们基本上没有在思考的更深层次的机构目标。当然，当这些目标因为没有被明确表达而未能达成时，没有人会注意到它们的缺席。因此，如果你没有出现在面试中，人们会注意到；但如果你没有写出那本畅销书或下一个伟大的创意，人们是不会注意到的。所以这其中确实存在一种文化偏见，倾向于琐碎的事情，而不是保护真正最重要的事情。我非常赞同这一点，我还要补充一点，我认为其中很大一部分原因是缺乏衡量标准。如果我们看看两个并行的案例研究，两个不同的行业。
Let's look at the industrial revolution and the rise of mass industrial production. This was a world where the metrics for productivity were very clear. How many cars per hour is our factory producing? And what we saw in that world where bottom line value is very easy to measure is that very quickly the structure of work moved away from what was convenient for the workers and towards what produced more value. It moved away from the old system and factories where you had people working teams at one spot in the floor to assemble the car towards things like the assembly line, which are incredibly inconvenient. It's very hard to manage
让我们看看工业革命和大规模工业生产的崛起。这是一个生产力衡量标准非常清晰的世界。我们的工厂每小时生产多少辆汽车？我们在这个底线价值很容易被衡量的世界里看到的是，工作结构非常迅速地从对工人方便的方向转向了产生更多价值的方向。它从旧的工厂系统（人们在车间的一个地方组成团队组装汽车）转向了诸如流水线之类的事情，这些事情极其不便。管理起来非常困难
the assembly line. It's very hard to get it right. It causes lots of issues. It's annoying, but it produces a lot more value. You move to digital knowledge work. We don't have those metrics. It's much harder to measure, okay, what's the cost to our bottom line if you're more distracted or less distracted. And so my conjecture is that without those metrics, we are going to fall back on these interpersonal or cultural biases. We're wired to be social. We don't want to upset someone. These type of biases take over because it's much harder to measure in this new world, the impact of different behaviors. I'm wondering if there's also a psychological explanation
装配线上。要把这个做好非常困难。它会引发很多问题。这很烦人，但它能产 productivity 多得多的价值。当你转向数字知识工作时。我们没有那种指标。衡量起来要难得多，好吧，如果你分心更多或更少，对我们的底线成本有什么影响。所以我的推论是，如果没有这些指标，我们将退回到这些内隐的人际或文化偏见中。我们的基因决定了我们要进行社交。我们不想惹恼别人。这类偏见占据了上风，因为在这个新世界里，衡量不同行为的影响要困难得多。我在想，是否还有一个心理学解释
for the phenomenon you're describing. I took a vacation a couple of weeks ago, and for the first time in a long time, I actually decided to unplug. So I didn't have internet access, I wasn't checking my email, I literally was cut off from things going on at work. And when I got back there were a number of things that had happened in my absence, some of which I wish I'd had the chance to weigh in on. But when I looked at the
来解释你所描述的现象。几周前我休假了，而且是很长一段时间以来第一次，我真的决定断网。所以我没有上网，没有查邮件，我真的与工作中的事情隔绝了。当我回来时，在我不在的期间发生了很多事情，其中有些事情我希望我有机会发表意见。但当我看到
aggregate, the overall conclusion I got was really that the world did just fine in my absence. Things went fine. I actually wasn't as indispensable as I thought I was. I'm wondering if that might be a psychological driver in people being unwilling to actually cut themselves off, because not only might they discover that they are more productive, but they might also discover the world is just fine. Thank you very much without you.
总体情况时，我得到的整体结论其实是，在我不在的时候，世界运转得很好。事情进展得很顺利。实际上，我并没有自己想象的那么不可或缺。我在想，这会不会是一个心理驱动力，导致人们不愿意真正断绝联系，因为他们不仅可能会发现自己更有生产力，而且还可能会发现，没有你，世界也一样运转得很好。非常感谢。
Yeah, I think that's one of three big psychological drivers that have led us to this world we're now of the sort of constant connectivity business. So that's certainly one, I think, this notion of we get a sense of meeting and usefulness out of constantly being involved in interaction. I think the other two psychological drivers, one is just we're wired to be tribal and it's very difficult for us psychologically to know there's an email waiting that we're not answering. And even if we know for a fact that the person who sent that message does not need a fast response, it still feels like we're at the tribal fire and there's a tribe
是的，我认为这是导致我们陷入现在这种持续连接业务世界的三个巨大心理驱动力之一。所以这肯定是一个，我认为，这种观念，即我们从不断参与互动中获得意义感和实用性。我认为另外两个心理驱动力，一个是我们的基因决定了我们要抱团，在心理上我们很难知道有一封电子邮件在等待着我们却没有回复。即使我们确切地知道发送该消息的人不需要快速响应，但感觉仍然像我们围坐在部落的篝火旁，有一个部落
member standing there tapping you on the shoulder and you're ignoring them. We just have a very hard time with that. And I think the third driver is knowledge work is much less structured. And so how do you prove to your organization or to your boss that you're valuable? And busyness as a proxy for productivity is something that a lot of people have defaulted to. Well, at the very least, if you see I'm sending lots of messages you know I'm working. And so I think those three different factors are all intertwining to get us to this place, where we find ourselves just constantly sending messages, as opposed to thinking hard thoughts or producing new things.
成员站在那里拍你的肩膀而你却在忽略他们。我们对此感到非常棘手。我认为第三个驱动力是知识工作的结构性要少得多。那么，你如何向你的组织或你的老板证明你是有价值的呢？忙碌作为生产力的代名词，是很多人默认的选择。好吧，至少，如果你看到我发送了大量消息，你就知道我在工作。因此，我认为这三个不同的因素交织在一起，把我们带到了这样一个地方，我们发现自己不断地发送消息，而不是进行深入思考或生产新的东西。
Kyle Newport is a computer science professor at Georgetown University. He's the author of Deep Work, Rules for Focus Success in a Distracted World. Kyle, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Well, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Oh, thank you. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ After the break, we'll go to a psychology lab that's trying to help people bounce back from interruptions more easily.
凯尔·纽波特是乔治城大学的计算机科学教授。他是《深度工作：在干扰世界中获得专注力的规则》一书的作者。凯尔，谢谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。嗯，谢谢你今天邀请我参加《隐藏的大脑》。哦，谢谢。 [♪ 片尾音乐播放 [♪ 休息过后，我们将前往一个心理学实验室，该实验室正试图帮助人们更轻松地从中断中恢复过来。
All it takes is a little electricity. You should start to feel something pretty soon, if you're already. I'm feeling a very, very mild tingling. That's coming up in just a moment. I'm Shankar Vedantam and you're listening to Hidden Brain. This is NPR. This is Hidden Brain.
只需要一点电流。如果你已经准备好了，你很快就会开始感觉到一些东西。我感觉到了非常非常轻微的刺痛。稍后就会呈现。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。这是NPR。这是《隐藏的大脑》。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. Earlier in the show, I talked to the computer science professor Kall Newport about how important and rare it is these days to carve out time for uninterrupted work. He shared some ideas about how to develop deep attention. These ideas, no surprise, require real commitment and resolve. So I decided to explore a shortcut. A few months ago I was driving to Virginia for an interview and I was doing the opposite of D-Frog.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在节目早些时候，我采访了计算机科学教授卡尔·纽波特，谈到了如今腾出时间进行不间断工作是多么重要和罕见。他分享了一些关于如何培养深度专注力的想法。毫无疑问，这些想法需要真正的承诺和决心。所以我决定寻找一条捷径。几个月前，我开车去弗吉尼亚州参加一个面试，我做的事与深度工作截然相反。
I was watching the road paying attention to GPS directions and I was listening to an interview I had conducted years ago with a researcher Eric Lumber. I was on my way to an interview with one of Eric's colleagues and I needed to re-familiarize myself with the material. So the irony here of course is that I'm heading to an interview about interruptions while being constantly interrupted. The interview I was going to was about how to deal with interruptions and distractions.
我看着路，注意着GPS导航，听着我几年前对研究员埃里克·伦伯进行的采访。我在去采访埃里克的一位同事的路上，我需要重新熟悉这些材料。所以这里的讽刺之处当然是，我正前往一个关于中断的采访，却不断地被打断。我要去的采访是关于如何处理中断和分心的。
Now, there's no question. I'd love to do my deep thinking and the kinds of places Cal Newport described, places like Carl Jung's Lakeside House and the Swiss countryside or JK Rowling's Suite in Edinburgh. But since I've chosen a life in public radio, I need something a little more... I was gonna say cheap, but why don't we say practical? That's where Eric and his colleague Melissa Scheldrup come in. They're exploring a relatively simple solution to the problem of interruptions and overwork. Basically, you run a small electrical current through part of the brain and voila!
现在，毫无疑问。我很乐意在卡尔·纽波特描述的那种地方进行深度思考，比如瑞士乡村卡尔·荣格的湖畔小屋或J.K.罗琳在爱丁堡的套房。但既然我选择了公共广播的生活，我需要更...本想说便宜，但我们为什么不说实用呢？这就是埃里克和他的同事梅利莎·舍尔德鲁普发挥作用的地方。他们正在探索一个相对简单的解决方案来解决中断和过度工作的问题。基本上，就是通过大脑的一部分传微小的电流，然后奇迹就发生了！
It's easier to manage interruptions. It's now year since this interview with Eric, a new researcher has taken over the project and I'm heading to the lab along with my producer, Raina Cohen. I've offered myself over as a guinea pig for the experiment and I'm a little worried. The squeals of pain coming from the host is what makes this worthwhile. Rayna doesn't show much sympathy. Putting your money where your math is, you've been reaping the rewards of the many undergraduate students who have subjected themselves to social science research and now you have to be part of it.
更容易应对中断了。距离对埃里克的采访已经过去了一年，一位新的研究人员接管了这个项目，我和我的制作人雷娜·科恩一起前往实验室。我自愿成为实验的小白鼠，我有点担心。主持人发出的痛苦尖叫声正是让这一切变得值得的原因。雷娜并没有表现出太多的同情。身体力行，你一直在享受许多本科生作为社会科学研究对象的成果，现在你也必须成为其中的一部分。
Faire is fair. As fair as it might be, the idea of running an electrical current through my head is not exactly appealing, but the possibility that I could juggle the many demands on my time, that's irresistible. Something hugely seductive about this idea that you can wear a helmet
公平就是公平。尽管可能很公平，但把电流通进我的脑袋里的想法绝对不怎么吸引人，但我可以兼顾我时间的多种需求的可能性，那是不可抗拒的。关于这个想法有一些极具诱惑力的地方，你可以戴上头盔
and instead of being able to do one thing at a time You can now do four things at a time Wait, which way am I going now? I decided to turn off the interview with Eric and focus on the road Once I make it at the campus of George Mason I find my way to Melissa's lab. It turns out to be less sci-fi find my way to Melissa's lab. It turns out to be less sci-fi than grunge. They keep us grad students' placements, so I can't go through the no window.
而不是一次只能做一件事 你现在可以一次做四件事 等等，我现在该往哪个方向走？我决定关掉对埃里克的采访，专心开车。一到乔治梅森的校园，我就找到了梅利莎的实验室。结果发现与其说是科幻找到梅利莎的实验室。不如说它更像是垃圾摇滚风。他们保留了研究生的实验室，所以我不能从没有窗户的地方穿过去。
This is Melissa Scheldrup, Eric's colleague and my guide for the experiment. I am a sixth year graduate student in the PhD program at George Mason University in the Human Factors and Applied Cognition program. She takes me to her office. The room has white walls, fluorescent lights, no windows. Stacked cardboard boxes and stray electronics are strewn around. Old computers, new computers,
这是梅利莎·舍尔德鲁普，埃里克的同事，也是我这次实验的向导。我是乔治梅森大学人类因素与应用认知项目博士项目的第六年研究生。她带我去了她的办公室。房间有白色的墙壁，荧光灯，没有窗户。堆积的纸箱和散落的电子产品散落各处。旧电脑，新电脑，
a microwave for some reason. Melissa's work at the Human Factors in Applied Cognition Research Lab is inspired by a single insight. There's a reason some people bounce back from interruptions quickly and other people don't. One thought with interruptions is that they are highly dependent on a person's working memory capacity, so your natural ability to manipulate information in your brain. People who are generally good at that have less of a negative effect of interruptions and people who are not so good at it seem to be affected more. Melissa and her colleagues want to know if there's a way to improve working memory. In other words, can you help people hold more information in their heads? If you can do this, interruptions might not be such a big problem.
不知为何还有一个微波炉。梅利莎在人类因素与应用认知研究实验室的工作灵感来自于一个单一的洞察。有些人能从中断中迅速恢复过来，而另一些人则不能，这是有原因的。关于中断的一个想法是，它们高度依赖于个人的工作记忆容量，也就是你大脑中处理信息的先天能力。通常在这方面表现出色的人受到的中断负面影响较小，而表现不太好的人似乎受到的影响更大。梅利莎和她的同事想知道是否有一种方法可以改善工作记忆。换句话说，你能帮助人们在脑海中保留更多信息吗？如果你能做到这一点，中断可能就不会成为那么大的问题。
That brings us to the brain's app. If you want to influence how people deal with interruptions, it makes sense to try and stimulate a part of the brain that handles working memory, the prefrontal cortex. Very simplistically, it's like a 9 volt battery that we have electrodes attached to, and depending on where you put the electrodes on the brain, you can either make it more difficult for neurons to fire or make it more easy for them to fire. Scientists have long inserted electrodes into the brain to change the way the brain works. Doing this helps patients with serious disorders like Parkinson's disease.
这就把我们带到了大脑的应用程序。如果你想影响人们如何处理中断，尝试刺激处理工作记忆的大脑部分——前额叶皮层，这是合情合理的。简单来说，它就像一个连有电极的9伏电池，根据你将电极放在大脑的哪个位置，你可以让神经元更难放电，或者让它们更容易放电。长期以来，科学家们一直在大脑中植入电极来改变大脑的工作方式。这样做有助于帕金森病等严重疾病的患者。
I've signed up for a much less invasive procedure and electrode attached to the side of my head. Now, obviously, running a small current through the brain is a crude way to change how it works. So this really is a little bit like just slapping the side of the television set, isn't it? There's a lot of that. Yep, there's a lot of wiggle room in how it works.
我已经报名了一个侵入性小得多的程序，一个连接在我头部侧面的电极。现在，很明显，通过大脑运行微小的电流是一种改变其工作方式的粗糙方法。所以这实际上有点像拍打电视机的侧面，对吧？有很多这样的情况。是的，它如何运作有很大的发挥空间。
I'm often juggling multiple things at the same time. So what would be your hypothesis on what the effect is of this helmet on my behavior and performance? I would, if we're gonna extend it out there to your entire life, it should, in theory, help you juggle all the multitask you have going on. If you need a working memory boost, then it will allow you to focus on one thing, stop focusing on that, move to something else, and then go back and pick up where you were
我经常同时处理多项任务。那么，关于这个头盔对我的行为和表现的影响，你的假设是什么？我会，如果我们把它扩展到你的整个生活，它在理论上应该可以帮助你兼顾你正在进行的所有多任务处理。如果你需要提高工作记忆，那么它将允许你专注于一件事，停止专注于那件事，转向别的事情，然后再回去从你离开的地方继续
without much of a degradation of performance, ideally. That's the goal. And what is the potential downside? Well, if you were to invest in a system like this, there's no guarantee it's going to work. There's really no negative effects that have been associated with it. There's always a possibility that we're
而性能不会有太大下降，理想情况下。这就是目标。那么潜在的缺点是什么？好吧，如果你要投资这样一个系统，无法保证它会起作用。与它相关的真的没有负面影响。总有一种可能性，我们
heading the wrong area in the brain. We don't do brain scans before we do this on people because it is pretty diffuse. So we could be you know accidentally While enhancing your working memory. We could also be hurting your verbal skills. Oh great So yes, but it's it's all transitori It's gonna stop once the stimulation stops are shortly thereafter. So it's it's not permanent The electrical stimulation won't affect me permanently
击中了大脑的错误区域。我们在对人进行这项操作之前不进行脑部扫描，因为它是相当弥散的。所以你可能知道不小心 在增强你的工作记忆的同时。我们也可能会损害你的语言技能。哦，太棒了 所以是的，但这一切都是暂时的 刺激一停止或不久之后它就会停止 所以它不是永久的 电气刺激不会永久地影响我
But what about helping me deal with interruptions in the short term? To find out Melissa has me play a computer game. So you're going to be playing a game called Worship Commander? It looks a lot like battleship. It has a 1990s video game feel to it. There's a very dark blue background, and my ship is at the bottom of the screen, and planes of different kinds are coming in from the top. I have to shoot down enemy planes and let friendly ones get through. There are lots and lots of rules.
但帮助我在短期内应对中断呢？为了找出答案，梅利莎让我玩一个电脑游戏。所以你要玩一个名为“战舰指挥官”的游戏。它看起来很像战舰。它有一种20世纪90年代电子游戏的感觉。背景是非常深蓝色，我的船在屏幕底部，各种各样的飞机从顶部飞来。我必须击落敌机，让友机通过。这里有许许多多的规则。
If it is an enemy, you warn it, here with the warn button, wait 5 seconds and then fire on it. Red planes are enemies, blue planes are friends, but then there are yellow planes, which could be either friend or foe. If it's yellow, what you'll need to do is click on it, find the highlighted number here on the side, click on that, and then it will tell you here in the communications window if it's a friend or a foe. Okay, click this button to shoot down foes, make sure you don't shoot friends, and a complicated
如果它是敌人，你警告它，在这里使用警告按钮，等待5秒钟然后向它开火。红色的飞机是敌人，蓝色的飞机是朋友，但还有黄色的飞机，可能是朋友也可能是敌人。如果是黄色，你需要做的是点击它，找到旁边突出的数字，点击它，然后它会在通信窗口中告诉你它是朋友还是敌人。好的，点击这个按钮击落敌人，确保你不要射击朋友，还有一个复杂的
system to figure out who is who. I'm ready to go, but those are all just the rules of the main task. While you're doing that, you're going to be hearing some information from the rest of your staff on the worship. And it's going to be things like your current water level is 355, our current communications channel is Oscar. And they're going to be giving you several updates while you're playing. Are these updates relevant to the game or can I just ignore them? So then somebody's going to come on and ask you, all right, what's the current communication?
系统来弄清楚谁是谁。我已经准备好了，但这些都只是主任务的规则。当你这样做时，你会听到战舰上其他工作人员的一些信息。诸如你目前的水位是355，我们当前的通信频道是奥斯卡之类的内容。他们会在你游戏时给你提供几次更新。这些更新与游戏相关吗，还是我可以忽略它们？然后会有人来问你，好吧，当前的通信是什么？
Oh, right. So that's the interrupting task, then you need to answer the question and then you can go back to what you're doing. So there are lots of rules and lots of moving parts. Naturally I do the mature thing and make up excuses even before the game starts. Can I just say that your volunteers don't have to play the game with a microphone one inch in front of their mouths? If you would like to have that as a caveat and a handicap, then yeah, you can put that on there.
哦，对了。这就是中断任务，然后你需要回答问题，然后你可以回到你正在做的事情上。所以有许多规则和许多运动部件。自然地，我做了一件成熟的事，甚至在游戏开始前就找借口。我能说你们的志愿者不必嘴前含着一英寸麦克风玩游戏吗？如果你想把它作为一个附加条件和障碍，那么是的，你可以把它放在那里。
I play a practice run. All right, I'm still getting used to all the elements of the game. Was I listening to what? The current course. Uh, no, I have no idea what the current course is. You have 10 seconds of answer and then it goes away, so you'll get the next one. Now that I know the rules, I start a new game. This time, the results count.
我进行了一次练习。好的，我还在习惯游戏的所有元素。我在听什么？当前的航向。呃，不，我不知道当前的航向是什么。你有10秒钟的时间回答，然后它就消失了，所以你会得到下一个。既然我知道了规则，我开始了一场新游戏。这一次，结果算数。
They're going to give me a baseline score that Melissa can later compare to how I do with the electrodes on. I destroy some enemy planes. I get a few things right. Yes. Though I also lose my cool. I warn you. But I'm kind of fine. Yeah, and it's not fine.
他们将给我一个基准分数，梅利莎随后可以将其与我戴着电极时的表现进行比较。我摧毁了一些敌机。我答对了几道题。是的。虽然我也失去了冷静。我警告你。但这没关系。是的，这没关系。
You have to wait five seconds. You have to give him a chance to get out of your airspace. And I make some mistakes. What is that current course? I think it's 030. I think. Oh no, I guess not. Once the game is over, Melissa gives me a performance evaluation.
你必须等五秒钟。你必须给他一个离开你的空域的机会。我犯了一些错误。当前的航向是什么？我想是030。我想是。哦不，我想不是。游戏结束后，梅利莎给我做了一次表现评估。
She thinks I did. Okay. You were very focused on the primary task, and not so much the interruption task. So what do we know next, and how do you improve my performance? All right, so now we put on the helmet. Melissa put some things on the table. A little black box with knobs, which is known as a trans-cranial direct currents simulation unit.
她认为我做得还可以。你非常专注于主要任务，而对中断任务不太专注。那么我们接下来知道什么，你如何改善我的表现？好吧，现在我们戴上头盔。梅利莎在桌子上放了一些东西。一个带有旋钮的小黑盒，被称为经颅直流电刺激装置。
Some cords, electrodes which look like squares that have rubber on the edges and thin sponges in the middle. Melissa prepares my head and arm before she attaches the electrodes. Don't be nervous. Don't be nervous.
一些电线，电极看起来像边缘有橡胶、中间有薄海绵的正方形。梅利莎在连接电极之前为我的头部和手臂做准备。不要紧张。不要紧张。
It's not nervous, not nervous, not nervous. It's all great. All great. I will live. I'm an expert. Yes. Sort of. She wipes a spot on my forehead, then on my upper arm. She picks up a syringe to add saline to the electrodes. Before I came to the lab, I thought it was going to be wearing a helmet for this experiment, so I asked Melissa why she isn't giving me one. It turns out the helmet is still in the idea stage. A standard helmet won't work because everyone has a different head size.
不紧张，不紧张，不紧张。一切都很好。一切都很好。我会活下来的。我是专家。是的。算是吧。她擦拭了我额头上的一个点，然后是我的上臂。她拿起一个注射器将生理盐水加到电极上。在我来到实验室之前，我以为这次实验我要戴着头盔，所以我问梅利莎为什么不给我一个。原来头盔还处于构思阶段。标准的头盔行不通，因为每个人的头围大小都不同。
What I get instead are white bandages wrapped around my head and arm. There's no mirror, so the only two people in the room with me, Melissa and my producer, they tell me how I look. You kind of look like a World War I patient that got hit in the head and has a white band around your forehead. This is really like Richard Simmons sweat band plus like the cable that you put in the back of the TV to set up the audio, like a little red plug. Yeah, yeah, it looks a lot like that.
我得到的替代品是缠在我头和手臂上的白色绷带。没有镜子，所以房间里仅有的两个人，梅利莎和我的制作人，他们告诉我我看起来怎么样。你看起来有点像第一次世界大战中头部受伤、额头上缠着白带的病人。这真的很像理查德·西蒙斯（Richard Simmons）的运动发带，再加上你插在电视机背面用来设置音频的电缆，像一个红色的插头。对，对，看起来确实很像那样。
Then there's my arm. The electrode feels like a medical device. Which looks kind of like a blood pressure cuff? Melissa asks me if I'm ready, and I say yes. You should start to feel something pretty soon, if you don't already. I'm feeling a very very mild tingling it feels I how to describe it but just like a
然后是我的手臂。电极感觉像是一种医疗设备。看起来有点像血压袖带？梅利莎问我准备好了吗，我说准备好了。如果你还没感觉到，你很快就会开始感觉到一些东西。我感觉到了非常非常轻微的刺痛，感觉我怎么形容呢，就像一个
Slightly burning sensation, but it's fairly mild and it's fairly focused and intense and it's right over my right Temple With electricity running through my skull, I start the game again. Alright. New and improved chunker with superpowers of concentration. I'm going to start the experiment now. This time I get four out of six questions right on the interruption task.
轻微的灼烧感，但它相当温和，相当集中和强烈，就在我的右太阳穴上方。随着电流通过我的头骨，我再次开始了游戏。好的。带着专注超能力的全新改进版尚卡尔。我现在要开始实验了。这一次，我在中断任务中答对了六分之四的问题。
I improved. But that could be just a fluke. I think so. I play another game. You got them all right. Alright. Melissa explains exactly what all the plane destroying and messages about freshwater levels actually reveal about my working memory.
我进步了。但这可能只是运气。我想是的。我玩了另一局游戏。你全都答对了。好的。梅利莎准确地解释了所有的飞机摧毁和关于淡水水位的消息实际上揭示了我的工作记忆的什么。
I have to remember the game's complicated rules. That takes up some of my working memory. I have to keep track of the constant verbal updates. These interruptions mean I have to store all this information in my head, even as I'm trying to keep enemy planes from blowing me up. The key thing that Melissa is measuring about the interruptions is... What happens after you respond to that task? Are you able to go back right away and pick up where you were?
我必须记住游戏复杂的规则。这占用了一些我的工作记忆。我必须跟上不断的口头更新。这些中断意味着我必须把所有这些信息记在脑子里，即使我正试图阻止敌机炸毁我。梅利莎对中断测量的关键是...你在回应那个任务之后会发生什么？你能够马上回去并从你离开的地方继续吗？
How would you say I performed? You performed pretty well for being your second game or third game. You did pretty well especially with the interrupting task. I was very impressed. Normally we have to remind people that they need to focus on that and try it. Do you think that the electrodes made a difference? As a scientist I cannot say that with an end of one and two games. It's very rare you see something that's like you can identify visually that somebody is better from intervention Right away like this and so it's over time looking at data
你觉得我的表现怎么样？作为你的第二场游戏或第三场游戏，你表现得相当不错。你做得很好，特别是在中断任务上。我印象非常深刻。通常我们必须提醒人们他们需要专注于此并尝试。你认为电极起了作用吗？作为一名科学家，我不能在只有一个人和两场游戏的情况下这么说。你很少看到那种可以从视觉上识别某人在干预后立即变好的情况，所以这需要随着时间推移查看数据
So I could go looking at your data and look at during the practice games What happened after you answer those questions? How long did it take you to make your next step? Did you make the correct next step? Did you go back? Did you skip things? And then compare them numerically to how you did with the electrodes on. I asked Melissa if I should strap electrodes to my head when I'm dealing with interruptions at work. You could do that. This probably isn't the
所以我可以去查看你的数据，看看在练习游戏期间你回答了那些问题后发生了什么？你花了多长时间做出你的下一步？你做出正确的下一步了吗？你回去了吗？你跳过事情了吗？然后将它们与你戴着电极时的表现进行数值比较。我问梅利莎，当我在工作中处理中断时，我是否应该在头上绑上电极。你可以这么做。这可能不是
best real-world technique, but there are it informs other techniques. So if we know that modulating working memory performance or working memory ability affects these things, then we can say what techniques can maybe supplement your working memory. When Melissa and her colleagues analyze the results, they take all kinds of factors into account. For example, it may be that people are better at multitasking after some time,
现实世界中最好的技术，但它为其他技术提供了信息。因此，如果我们知道调节工作记忆表现或工作记忆能力会影响这些事情，那么我们就可以说哪些技术也许可以补充你的工作记忆。当梅利莎和她的同事分析结果时，他们考虑了各种因素。例如，人们在一段时间后可能更擅长多任务处理，
just because they've had more practice with the game. It might be that when they wear the electrodes, there's a placebo effect going on, they think they're gonna do better, and so they actually do better. But when Melissa and her colleagues take all of this and other factors into account, the electrodes still seem to make a difference. So I have a question that's not really a science question, it might be more of a philosophical
仅仅因为他们对游戏进行了更多练习。可能是当他们戴着电极时，存在安慰剂效应，他们认为自己会表现得更好，所以他们实际上表现得更好。但当梅利莎和她的同事将所有这些和其他因素考虑在内时，电极似乎仍然产生了影响。所以我有一个不是真正的科学问题的问题，它可能更像是一个哲学
question. I remember when we started using smartphones and they seemed like enormous time saving devices, they allowed you to do in five minutes what used to take you two hours. And initially, the argument was, you now are gonna have an hour and 55 minutes to take a walk in the park and smell the roses. But of course, that isn't what happened. We just fill the hour and 55 minutes
问题。我记得当我们开始使用智能手机时，它们看起来像是巨大的省时设备，它们让你能在五分钟内完成过去需要两个小时才能完成的事情。最初，争论的焦点是，你现在将有一个小时零五十五分钟去公园散步，闻闻玫瑰花香。但当然，事情并非如此。我们只是把一个小时零五十五分钟
with other stuff to do. And now you're just as busy, probably even more busy than you were before, except you're doing 20 tasks instead of one. And I'm wondering, as we come up with these techniques that might actually improve the efficiency with which our brains work, is it possible that we'll just simply use the balance of time to do even more stuff? I think that's exactly correct.
填满了其他要做的事情。现在你和以前一样忙，可能比以前更忙，只是你在做20个任务而不是一个任务。我在想，随着我们想出这些实际上可以提高我们大脑工作效率的技术，我们是否可能只是简单地用剩余的时间去做更多的事情？我认为这完全正确。
There's a debate going on in this field and in cybernics in general, should we really be doing these things? Is it really helpful to humanity or the person? And my feeling is that we've always made technological advances and they've always been at the aim of making things easier for humans and also think that you have a choice, right? You can choose to use these tools to make you more efficient and then go on a hike or a walk.
这个领域和网络学总体上正在进行一场辩论，我们真的应该做这些事情吗？这对人类或个人真的有帮助吗？我的感觉是，我们一直在取得技术进步，它们的宗旨一直是让人类的生活更轻松，我也认为你有一种选择，对吧？你可以选择使用这些工具让你更有效率，然后去远足或散步。
Or you can choose to use these tools to make you more efficient and then go on a hike or a walk. Or you can choose to use these tools to make you more efficient and then you go do more work. That is a personal choice that I think everyone has to make. We were just talking with Kal Newport. He's a professor of computer science at Georgetown University and he's the author of a new book that looks at Deep Work, the idea that we are doing too many things and the way to actually be less busy and to be more focused is actually just to be less busy, to take on fewer things, to say no to many more things, and to carve out time where we can actually stay and focus on things. And I'm wondering what he would say to this kind of intervention. And I think he would say you're trying to find sort of a technical solution to what
或者你可以选择使用这些工具让你更有效率，然后去远足或散步。或者你可以选择使用这些工具让你更有效率，然后去做更多的工作。我认为这是每个人都必须做出的一种个人选择。我们刚刚和卡尔·纽波特交谈过。他是乔治城大学的计算机科学教授，他是一本新书的作者，该书探讨了深度工作，这个想法是我们正在做太多的事情，而要真正做到不那么忙碌和更加专注的方法实际上就是减少忙碌，承担更少的事情，对更多的事情说不，并腾出时间让我们真正能够停留并专注于事情。我想知道他对这种干预会说些什么。我想他会说你是在试图为一个
is really a human behavior problem. And the technical solution is let's make the brain 5% better than it was before, but of course when you do that, you're just going to take on 10% more work. Yeah, I personally don't think that TDCS should be used in some of these everyday life. It should be used as a tool to look at the underlying physiological process. So I don't think that everybody should have a helmet that has this. It's like cheating. And so what really needs to be done is have people out in the forefront who understand these issues and then they can present it to the general public in a way that makes sense.
真正的人类行为问题寻找技术解决方案。技术解决方案是让我们的大脑比以前好5%，但当然，当你这样做时，你只会承担多10%的工作。是的，我个人认为经颅直流电刺激（TDCS）不应该用于某些日常生活。它应该被用作观察底层生理过程的工具。所以我不认为每个人都应该戴一个有这个的头盔。这就像作弊。因此，真正需要做的是让走在前沿的了解这些问题的人将其实际情况以合理的方式呈现给公众。
So yes, we have this ability to change the, you know, neural functioning of your brain within a few minutes, but here's how and why we should use that, and here's how we shouldn't use that, and really have a lot of thought put into it for introducing these things into the public. Hmm. Because in some ways I'm wondering,
所以是的，我们有能力在几分钟内改变你大脑的神经功能，但这是我们应该如何以及为什么使用它，以及我们不应该如何使用它的方式，并在将这些东西引入公众之前进行大量思考。嗯。因为在某些方面我在想，
you know, what we lack is not sort of our ability to multitask, but our ability to actually sit with things. Really, I think that is a more like cultural and societal issue that we have. So, you know, I know some people who are really good at saying, no, I just, I don't wanna do that. And then I know other people who would never say no to an opportunity, even though it means more work.
你知道，我们缺乏的不是我们多任务处理的能力，而是我们真正静下心来面对事物的能力。真的，我认为这更像是一个文化和社会问题。所以，你知道，我认识一些人，他们真的很擅长说，不，我就是不想做那件事。然后我认识另一些人，他们永远不会对一个机会说不，即使这意味着更多的工作。
And as a graduate student, I can fully attest to that. And I'm sure, I'll help you out, sure, I'll do this. I don't need to sleep, it's fine. I'm in the gym in six months. And so I think that's more of a cultural thing and needs to be something that's addressed. And that people in technology, sectors, or in science, if we allow them to go on a hike and a walk,
作为一名研究生，我完全可以证明这一点。我确信，我来帮你，好的，我来做这个。我不需要睡觉，没关系的。我六个月内在健身房。所以我认为这更像是一种文化问题，需要得到解决。技术领域或科学领域的人，如果我们允许他们去远足和散步，
that's been shown to sort of give you these aha moments and actually help your cognition. And so if we change the way we thought about it that way, where yes, we're going to make this more efficient, but that rest of the time is yours, instead of, we're going to make this more efficient, and that time is still mine. That would be my ultimate solution.
事实证明，这会给你带来这些顿悟时刻，并真正帮助你的认知。因此，如果我们以这种方式改变我们的看法，是的，我们将使这更有效率，但其余的时间是你的，而不是，我们将使这更有效率，而时间仍然是我的。这将是我的最终解决方案。
Each year, we learn a whole lot more about how the brain works. In the future, maybe we will have helmets that we can wear at work. They'll allow us to be more focused or juggle multiple demands. There's nothing wrong with trying to get the most out of our brains, any more than there's something wrong and trying to get the most out of our legs or our hands. If there are machines that can help us lift heavier things than we ever thought possible, and machines that can help us move faster than we ever imagined,
每年，我们对大脑工作原理的了解都在增加。在未来，也许我们会拥有可以在工作中佩戴的头盔。它们将使我们能够更加专注或应对多种需求。试图充分利用我们的大脑并没有什么错，就像试图充分利用我们的腿或手没有什么错一样。如果有机器可以帮助我们举起比我们想象的更重的物体，以及帮助我们以比我们想象的更快的速度移动的机器，
there are certainly going to be machines one day to help us think faster or more clearly. In fact, you can argue this is exactly what an education does. You spend years in school or hours reading books or listening to a radio show like this one to improve how your brain works. But in the end, technology is just a tool. We need wisdom to know how to use it. A helmet or a phone can't tell you if it's a good idea to push your brain to work twice as fast or if working too hard might make you unhappy.
将来肯定也会有一天出现机器来帮助我们更快或更清晰地思考。事实上，你可以争辩说，这正是教育的作用。你在学校里度过了几年，或者花了几小时读书或收听像这样的广播节目来改善大脑的工作方式。但归根结底，技术只是一种工具。我们需要智慧来知道如何使用它。头盔或手机无法告诉你强迫你的大脑工作速度加倍是否是个好主意，或者过度工作是否会让你感到不快乐。
For those answers, you need that leg side retreat or at least a quiet walk in the woods. acquired walk in the woods. This episode was produced by Raina Cohen and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jennie Schmidt, Maggie Pennman, Renée Clar and Bart Schaude. NPR's vice president for programming and audience development is Anja Grunman. If you like the show, check out our weekly podcast. Search for Hidden Brain on NPR1 iTunes or wherever you find your podcast. You can also follow the show on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and listen to my stories on morning edition.
对于这些答案，你需要那个湖畔静修处，或者至少在树林里安静地散步。在树林里安静地散步。这一集由雷娜·科恩制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特、玛吉·彭曼、勒内·克拉尔和巴特·肖德。NPR负责节目和受众开发的副总裁是安娅·格伦曼。如果你喜欢这个节目，请查看我们的每周播客。在NPR1、iTunes或你找到播客的任何地方搜索“隐藏的大脑”。你也可以在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上关注这个节目，并在《早间版》上收听我的故事。
I'm Shankar Vedantam, see you next week. System shut down complete. System shut down complete. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，下周见。系统关机完成。系统关机完成。该集目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子发表评论。